we recently wrapped up a non-scientific
poll of only our audience at david
pakman.com so just to be super clear I'm
not presenting this as a properly
sampled national poll that has balanced
income and party affiliation and race
and gender & movie preferences and what
kind of coffee you drink in the morning
this is just an unscientific sample of
our viewers who were asked what scares
you the most about the upcoming donald
trump presidency and the results are in
and i want to share them with you okay
the number one concern for members of
our audience about the incoming trump
administration is conflicts of interest
and corruption thirty-five percent of
our viewers are most concerned by
conflicts of interest in corruption in
the upcoming trump administration i
almost want to say the upcoming trump
nuptials but that's not really what
we're talking about but he is kind of
getting married to the united states in
a way uh twenty four percent of our
viewers are most concerned about social
policy that will be enacted under donald
trump for me that's mostly pense because
i don't see Trump as the social
conservative ideologue although again
because he does whatever the last thing
is someone mentions to him if Pence's
talking to him a lot that's cause for
concern on social policy well I guess
it's true that he is not the most
steadfast in his beliefs of social
policy that he's going to take the
conservative positions but the issue is
that if he's going to appoint people to
the Supreme Court who are more I'd a lot
ideologically conservative yep that's
where the issue comes when he talks
about anti-choice Supreme Court nominees
that that's definitely concerned so
combined fifty-nine percent of our
audience is most concerned in in terms
of either conflicts of interest in
corruption or social policy thirteen
percent of our audience is most scared
about economic policy that will be
enacted by Donald Trump and I think
that's that's warranted especially since
he's already taking credit for jobs that
he has nothing to do with having saved
or created we saw the Ford story the
Fiat story etcetera eleven percent of
our audience is most concerned with
something else something other than the
options listed here and six percent of
our audience and there's probably some
self selection by
here six percent of our audience is not
concerned about anything in terms of the
incoming Trump administration nothing
make America great again was their
chosen response what scares me the most
other than something happening to trump
and mike pence being the next president
uh probably relates more to the culture
of ignorance that Trump is perpetrating
by sort of pre-empting any critiques of
Trump by saying it's either fake news or
biased or untrustworthy or bomb throwers
the anti-intellectual explosion that
we've seen in the US over the last 30 or
40 years I worry will only escalate more
more quickly under Donald Trump and that
will have there's no such thing as
trickle-down economics the trickle-down
ignorance is really a concern for me yet
to borrow a phrase from Kanye West had I
voted in this poll I would have voted
for something else because my answer
would be foreign policy yes kind of
trivializing the impact of nuclear
weapons or deals with other foreign
leaders via Twitter and insults them I
think that's what I would go with some
of these other things can be undone in
future presidencies that's another way
to look at it which is what of what
Trump does can be undone Supreme Court
pics can't be undone not easily anyway
very very rare that that would happen
and and I think we have to evaluate what
of what Trump might do could we cancel
once we get someone else in office and
what is going to be there for a very
long time like multi-generational
Supreme Court pics gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / tdps the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support
our show by going to gamefly offer.com /
TDPS